des mordus de michel audiard ont des
quantités de choses gentilles se dire
michel audiard vous êtes analphabètes
vous n'avez froid de connaissances
particulières non vous n'avez pas un
physique spéciale n'est pas de chez nous
on n'avait pas de cheveux et vous avez
quand même fait une carrière de
dialoguiste
oui parce que j'ai rien de tout ce que
vous dites mais j'ai des lectures j'ai
du bic et a tout piqué vient absolument
rien de moins dans tout ce que j'écris
depuis 45 ans vous voulez
systématiquement je râle maintenant je
loue au procès je volais les idées je
les revendais maintenant je les loue on
les utilise le temps d'un film les rangs
c'est pour ça que tu n'aies fine jambes
c'est un point de vue ça vous a donné de
bons résultats ont tout le monde sait
nous parlons du dialoguiste en ce moment
mais dans un autre à bonne idée j'ai
constaté que vous n'avez aucune
connaissance technique que vous
confondez un zoom et un travelling
mélanger facilement les objectifs
oui et malgré ça vous avez fait une
carrière de metteur en scène à se passer
je suis passée mettant en scène parce
que je me suis aperçu que les mettant en
scène était affichée plus groupe les
auteurs et partant gagné plus de chou
alors j'aime pas le cinéma mais j'aime
les sous c'est donc une opération
purement commerciale
d'ailleurs il ya qu à voir mais si oui
c'est pour ça qu'il faut de l'argent
oui ce soir
voilà le résultat est là et vous avez le
sentiment que ça va durer longtemps
où ça je crois que le cinéma est la
seule forme de filouterie qui ne
contente pas de suites pénales
alors tout est possible
je vous remercie mille fois de ses
déclarations pertinentes et je pense que
les jeunes générations tiendront compte
et pourront à l'avenir penser avec votre
hygiène morale à l'avenir du cinéma
français vit sa pause que comme
l'interviewer pose des questions
intelligentes devraient pointer les
gamins michel audiard est aussi bien née
tensions dit que bien en vue du bien en
anglais mais pas de physique n'ont pas
de voix je porte je n'ai pas tué mais
pas de prestance
ça m'arrive enfin j'en ai pour beaucoup
comment expliquez-vous votre
interminable carrière d'acteur vous
savez une carrière d'acteur c'est très
simple un mais glorieuse aînée a dit un
jour conditionnelle parce qu'il avait
personne c'est encore autre chose il ya
personne qui sache faire du cinéma alors
fatalement les deux une pente des gens
qui se trouvent par la suite de devenir
des acteurs mais la formule c'est qu'on
se dise les maths parce que la personne
et on prend les gens comme un grand cru
les gens qui traînent quelquefois dans
des cours d'art dramatique et le
conservatoire que je crois dans les
théâtres mais on lui prend comme ça
oui car je me suis laissé dire ont
dépuis les attend ce que vous aviez fait
le conservatoire j'ai fait le
conservatoire elle est sortie à kehl en
jeu 10 fois la porte
ça ne m'étonne dans ça vous a rendu
service
et alors comment expliquer ou étant
donné votre manque évident en capacité
qu'en que les metteurs en scène ne
puisse absolument pas se passer de ça
c'est parce que les metteurs en scène
d'abord notre imagination et qu'ensuite
l'expérience m'a démontré qu'ils avaient
besoin de finalement ce qu'on appelait
des acteurs c'est quand on voit ce que
les autres
metteur en scène peuvent commettre comme
dialogue comme histoire comme âneries
il faut bien que les spécialistes pour
lui faire passer
d'après me valut les monastères ah oui
oui je connais énormément de dialoguiste
et d'auteurs pas de nous pas non il aura
tout macaci vraiment gardien francs et
je connais ton beaucoup de dialoguiste
qui volent des sujets et des histoires
et surtout des mots aux acteurs vous
avez fait combien de fait aucune idée
aucune idée autour de 120 130
environnement humeur c'est bien il ya
soixante ans que vous tournez beaucoup
plus j'ai tourné avant méliès et vous
pensez que cette escroquerie va se
prolonger indéfiniment aucune aventure
s'arrête quand on a un job qui est à
raquettes
soyons franc ribéry comme 10e frébault
garde c'est le seul raquette qui soit
valable qui ne soient pas punis
il ya pourquoi voulez vous que ça
s'arrête donc une réserve maintenant les
gens peuvent plus passer demain donc au
vert
le nadal de quoi dans n'importe quoi
donc on va se retrouver dans un film de
michel audiard
voilà